البنك الاهلي وابنك مصر وهما مصر في
المملوكان للدوله تحركها لاصدار شهادات
استثمار مدتها سنه بفائده 25% الهدف هو
اغراؤه حائز الدولار بتحويل ما لديه
للجنيه للاستفاده من هذا العائد فهل سيقبل
البعض عليها
ويجيب شهادات من اللي هي الجديده دين
العائد بتاعها عالي همم لان الدولار اكيد
اسعاره هتبقى متوازنه في السوق في المرحله
المقبله بعد اصدار هذه الشهاده
بانه بدايه التعويم الثالث لهذا العام
ووصفه اخرون انه دليل على مرونه سعر الصرف
في التماهي مع العرض والطلب
هذا تراجع في قيمه الجنيه امام الدولار
دعا بعض للتشكيك في مدى اقبال المصريين
على هذه الودائع تحرك اسعار الصرف او
انخفاض الجنيه كان مقيمه اكبر بكثير من
الشهادات الطرحه يعني احنا اعلى شهاده
تقريبا طرحت كانت 18% مازال هو ال ال اتجه
للشهادات هو برده ما قدرش ان هو يحافظ على
ثروته او همم
الممتلكات بتاعته مقاومه الدولار
هذا شكل من شانها ان يكذب المصريين للتخلي
عن الدولار مقابل عائد مادي مجزي ولكن في
نفس الوقت هذه الفائده المرتفعه تقول
الكثير عن الغلاء المتوقع في خادم الايام
تبين توقعته الشارع حول معدلات التضخم في
الفتره القادمه
مش مستنيها شهادات المصريين هيحطوا مبالغ
كبيره هيحطوا مبالغ كبيره جدا في في
البنوك فالنقد اللي معاهم في يديهم هيقل
فاعتقد دي هت كنترول شويه في اسعار السلع
اهي الحكومه المصريه وكانت قد اجلت تحريك
اسعار المحروقات والكهرباء كنوع من
التخفيف على المواطنين وبالتالي هناك ترقب
للاجتماع القادم للجنه المسؤوله عن تحديد
سعر الوقود لان هذا ايضا يشكل عاملا هاما
في تحديد التكلفه السلعه ومن ثم في تحديد
اسعارها تامر ناصر العربيه القاهره